we want to do something we want to do
something smaller and more like sorry
this is our little show about a girl in
boarding school and also to be honest we
wanted to do a show for our daughters
yeah because you have two daughters each
right yes yeah yeah and we also kind of
part of it was like like Smallville
which is like is there an iconic
character who's that there's a chapter
that hasn't been told and so we kind of
got to Wednesday Adams and then yeah you
have a uh sort of uh propensity yeah
yeah we own that I think we own that
corner now
teenage years teenage years yeah yeah so
what yeah it was so we were so we kind
of wanted to it's a little like getting
back to your roots little how do we
change it up how do we do something
that's in set present day even though
but who brought a building show do you
remember who brought it up it came well
it came out from Al because alivine had
been at MGM for with some friends and
and they were working on the animated
movie
um and Wednesday was the highest testing
character in the animated movie and we
thought oh that's a really interesting
oh so we're like oh if that what if
that's live and here's what's
interesting is they didn't know who had
the live-action TV rights so we
basically came up with a whole show on
spec you know so we wrote the whole and
then went to Paramount and then well we
we had and then this was also how about
the original live action movie no so we
thought oh who has it does Paramount
have it or because MGM was doing the
animated movies and it turned out that
MGM had the rights but they had a very
contentious relationship with the rights
holder who's who's a guy named Kevin
mizraki who was
um Charles Adams's
um like landscape architect who
befriended him and his wife and when
they died they left in the estate and
he's built it into this and actually
incredible
you know franchise what because I don't
I don't think what we either of us
appreciated was that The Adams Family is
still incredibly popular around the
world well clearly right no no but no no
but but I don't think but like we didn't
I don't think we sort of we're like
anyone appreciated The Adams Family but
we're like you know because there's a
there was a musical about 10 years ago
with Nathan Lane
um and I can't remember who played
Morticia it ran on Broadway for a year
to be honest not not a terribly good
show it has been the number one produced
High School show for the last 10 years
licensed so when people go what's my
spring musical gonna be it's The Adams
Family so interestingly kids know The
Adams Family the animated movie came out
and made 200 million dollars so it's one
of those things people love it people so
you're saying you sort of do the
research of you know demographically uh
uh genders who's watching is there is do
you do that before you come up with
ideas no no this was something where it
was like oh here's a character
nobody knew who had the rights
clearly just sitting out there it's not
here's the other thing it wasn't owned
by a studio right there was a there was
a separate Adams foundation and so we
um with the help Steve Stark was the
president of MGM television at the time
he's now a producer on the show and
Andrew mittman who was his executive and
they so we went in and we had done this
thing we pitched it to them they loved
it was like a 20 Page 20 Page detailed
Bible of what the series should be which
is very simple the show is yes it's with
all the characters and and the world and
the mythology of Nevermore and what the
first season would be in terms of laying
out the mystery stories it was and what
this part it was and this is all on spec
in terms of what we it's good we always
do this anyway just so we know what the
show is before we go pitch it yeah so
it's something we do whenever we do a
show right so they were like great we
don't even know if we have the rights we
pitched it but first we pitched it to
the rights holder who who really loved
it because he you know saw he said there
was a which is true there's a
sophistication to the Charles Adams
cartoons which he didn't feel got
captured in a lot of these animated
things they felt more Kitty and he liked
this because it felt more true to the to
the tone of of his original work so he
was on board right and then MGM threw
various legal things because of the
animated films had What's called the
right of of last negotiation so which
basically means if anybody else tried to
come in if MGM came in with like a
dollar more they could get the right so
MGM negotiated the rights and then we
went to we went out and pitched it
around town and had one buyer which was
Netflix so only one mile only one buyer
wait wait how many did you pitch we
pitched five at least and they all said
no